[Musique]
quand on a 16 ans et qu'on vit dans le
plus beau quartier de rome
on a de la chance en vie dans le
meilleur des mondes
et c'est pour ça que
pour survivre on a besoin d'une vie
secrète
c'est pas évident d'arriver en cours
d'année je ne me fais pas de souci pour
dans l'intégration
pourrais-tu me fait confiance comme ça
j'ai pas de potes bcbg mois
c'est dit d'aller faire un tour
je vois déjà la scène de nuit une belle
robe
tu sais chérie il ya des jeunes filles
du même âge que toi qui font toutes
sortes de bêtises
et une fois que les gens se sont fait
une opinion c'est impossible de revenir
en arrière
[Musique]
non
une pièce qui se passe en ce moment
tout va bien
oh
[Musique]
soit
j'ai pas besoin d'argent
tout est plus clair avec l'argent
salut à toi
[Musique]